well everybody the RTX 470 super is
officially being launched today though
you can go out and buy it tomorrow but
look I'm not going to pad this video
with a bunch of stuff that you don't
care about because this super well it's
actually a pretty straightforward GPU
what you get is more Coes than the
vanilla RTX 470 with pretty much
everything else staying the exact same
other than a slight bump in its base
clock and tgp there's one other little
tidbit buried in Nvidia spec sheet and
that's the addition of 14 more RS
bringing the count to 80 sure you don't
get more memory capacity or bandwidth
which is a bit of a disappointment but
it does slot into the RTX 470s MSRP of
$600 while the current card gets a small
price cut to $550 us the founders design
got a minor update too instead of the
silver accents from previous generations
all the super series cards this time get
a full blackout color scheme and
personally I love it and that dead sexy
Fe card won't be the only one available
for $600 because gpus like this Zotac
Trinity should also hit around that Mark
and those will likely be a whole lot
more broadly available from some
retailers rather than the founders
Edition just be aware though there's
going to be plenty of cards priced way
way above this which will completely
destroy the RTX 470 supers price to
Performance ratio so basically what
Nvidia is doing with this thing is
replacing their most popular GPU right
now at least according to the steam
Hardware survey which is the RTX 470
with a car that performs better and
costs the exact same amount of money you
should also remember the RTX 2070
Founders Edition also launched for $600
and I know it's 100 bucks More Than
People typically paid for the RTX 2070
super adjust for inflation though and
it's perfectly aligned so the RTX 470
superp is being built as the most
logical upgrade path for people still
holding on to those cards and this super
series card is just the first for this
generation there's also the RTX 470 TI
super which replaces the current RTX 470
TI and the RTX 480 super taking over
from the RTX 480 both of those are
straight up Replacements so the current
cards are getting discontinued rather
than living on at a lower price like the
4070 will be and you know what won't be
replaced anytime soon that's this case
from this video sponsor fantex I like it
so much it's currently my gaming case
for real the fantex nv5 the perfect
hybrid between the fish tank and your
regular mid Tower with visuals of your
components prioritized without
compromising on component fitment put in
your favorite AO at the top or the side
support the GPU hide the cables and
enjoy the buil-in lighting all for an
affordable yet elegantly matured
experience so you can Envy responsibly
my friends the mv5 check it out below
and please don't keep your case on the
floor gosh so that out of the way I want
to get right into performance testing
but there's also a couple of little
housekeeping points that I wanted to
make so this video will include all of
the cards that typically compete with
the the RTX 470 super in addition to
that I wanted to include sort of like an
upgrade path for previous generation
users and that would be the RTX 2070
super so this card right over here now
that's probably going to be the most
important point for people who are still
holding on to those older cards because
right now based on pricing and
everything else this is your natural
upgrade path also While most cards are
the founders Edition or amd's reference
design there are some models here with a
minor pre- overclock like the RTX 470 TI
and RX 7800 XT they don't offer more
than two to say 5% more performance
across the board than the standard
version but it's still something to take
into account as we go through the
results and starting with 1440p there
should be absolutely nothing that
surprises anyone here the su's
additional cores put it ahead of the RTX
470 sometimes buy a whole lot if a game
is core limited or less if there's a
memory bottleneck or something else in
the system holding it back nvidia's
strategy for this card is obviously lay
laser targeted make the RTX 470 super
justifiably better than the 4070 but
never allowed to get good enough to
challenge the 4070 TI we were also
promised that it would consistently beat
the RTX 390 and that's exactly what it
does in most situations at least these
numbers will obviously put a bit more
pressure on the 7800 XT as well though
we have to remember that card's a solid
$100 cheaper than super despite being
ultra competitive as a matter of fact
the two cards trade lows in most
situations provided a game isn't
completely AMD or Nvidia optimized like
some of these are that Trend between the
7800 XT and 470 super continues in 4k
now there's even more situations where
the XT ends up either closing the gap or
moving slightly ahead some of this could
be down to the AMD card's larger memory
footprint though 12 gigs should be more
than enough here or there's some
intrinsic architectural and optimization
advantages going on in some of these
games to its credit the super does does
make some meaningful improvements over
the vanilla 470 though it's not like
someone who has the regular card would
or even should upgrade to the super that
brings up another point though with just
$50 separating these two cards the RTX
470 now looks unbelievably overpriced if
I had to look into my crystal ball here
for a second Nvidia could be setting
this up as discount bait sometime in the
near future but right now I can't see a
single situation where I'd recommend a
4070 over the super or an RX 7800 XD
then again cut its price by too much and
it would cause a Cascade effect for the
4060 TI and 4062 and of course these
days there's also rate tracing to think
of and since both AMD and Nvidia offer
upscaling through the various iterations
of FSR and dlss RT has become much less
of a burden in most situations and yet
Nvidia still holds a distinct Advantage
across the board at both 1440p and 4K
which should surprise again absolutely
no one though it is interesting to see
that some games really do take advantage
of larger frame buffer sizes with rate
tracing enabled especially at 4K this is
also one area where the RTX 470 sup
updated RT cores lead to it more
consistently beating the RTX 390 whereas
the 3090 held a small Advantage within
some of these games in raster
performance so he basically just blitzed
through 11 games at two resolutions but
I also wanted to distill this down into
a little bit more understandable format
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do overall performance results that
average all of the results that we got
into one simple to understand chart so
overall it's obvious Nvidia wanted the
RTX 470 super to become the best
possible upgrade path for people with an
RTX 2070 series card to get there they
made it perform just good enough for a
meaningful improvement over the RTX 470
meanwhile RTX 470 TI buyers feel safe
their $800 investment isn't going to get
matched by a GPU that costs $200 less
the bigger question is whether or not in
raster performance at least the super
has what it takes to compete against the
much lower priced RX 7800 XT well both
cards tent to trade blows pretty evenly
at 1440p to the point where the lead
really comes down to the games you want
to play one thing is certain though I
don't think the super is going to put
any downwards pressure on the xt's price
not with that card costing on average so
much less yet still competing well at 4K
it also needs to be mentioned that this
is one area where nvidia's newest card
is also beaten by the RTX 390 by the
slimmest of margins even the RTX 470 TI
extends its lead so you really have to
wonder if 12 GB might really be the
culprit here we also can't forget things
like dlss frame generation Nvidia Studio
reflex and a bunch of other features do
hold a ton of value for a lot of Gamers
sure AMD has been trying to fight every
single one of those features but with
varying degrees of success that often
come off as completely half-baked with
that being said I really do feel like
the ace up nvidia's sleeve is not
necessarily their massive massive
feature set at least for people who are
upgrading for them it's actually the
efficiency of the RTX 4000 series cards
that's going to play a huge role in
their buying decision and these power
consumption numbers really Hammer that
point home of course they're higher than
the RTX 470 but on average the super
needs as much power as the RTX 2070
super despite offering double yes double
the performance performance per watt is
also higher than anything AMD is
offering right now and it even blows the
RTX 390 straight out of the water so
where does all this leave us well
personally I think that the RTX 470
super is basically what the RTX 470
should have been from day one and even
now this card is still a little bit too
conservative in its specs in order to
protect higher-end gpus in nvidia's
lineup but things are looking up for the
GeForce lineup because what the super
offers is still pretty darn compelling
especially for people looking to upgrade
from the 10 or 20 series while staying
in the Nvidia Camp its compact size at
least if you choose the founders Edition
will allow to fit in a broad range of
cases and that's especially important if
you're an ITX user and less power means
less heat being dumped into your case so
that's another win for small form factor
situations or folks with maybe a little
bit less air flow in their cases the
only negative is you'll still need to
Wrangle with that damn 12-pin power
connector the other complaint that some
folks might have is the lack of display
port 2.1 but that obviously wasn't in
the books without a significant
architectural update on the I/O side so
all in all the RTX 470 super isn't a
slam dunk by any stretch of the
imagination but what it is is a small
and good step forward to make nvidia's
lineup all that much more competitive
what you get is RTX 3090 performance at
2/3 of its power consumption and 40% of
its launch MSRP it just took us three
and a half years to get here so anyways
I'm Mike with Haru I hope you enjoyed
this relatively short GPU review and I
will see you in the next one have a
great day guys